hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
surf and turf simultaneous
spatio-temporal
super resolution and multi-parametric
fluorescence microscopy
my name is christy jewell i'm from lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by andor for more
information on our sponsor
you can click on the sponsor logo on the
left side of your screen
or visit andor.com now let's get started
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation also
please notice you can share today's
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's
live event now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing today's presentation
just click on that support tab found at
the top right of your presentation
window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
i would now like to introduce today's
presenters
torsten roland professor of biophysics
department of biological sciences and
chemistry at the national
university of singapore and dr alan
mullen
product specialist for microscopy
cameras at android
technology for complete biographies on
our speakers
please visit that biography tab at the
top of your screen
gentlemen welcome you may now begin your
presentations
hello and welcome to this webinar on
surf and turf simultaneous spatial
temple super resolution and
multi-parametric fluorescence microscopy
my name is thorsten walland and i'm from
the national university of singapore
experiments in this work have been
performed and evaluated by hari krishnan
bala subramanian and jaggery sankaran in
my group
jagadish and waihou tung from adrian
williams group have established the gpu
algorithms
and sonia monte the scientific
illustrator who interned in my lab
and helped with some of the graphics
well the good ones anyway
typically fluorescent measurements are
performed and optimized with a single
evaluation method in mind
however in principle the data contains
much more information if it can be mined
with multiple different evaluation
approaches
here i'd like to show this on the
example of spatial and temporal
resolution
and how we can maximize the extraction
of information from experiment by
optimizing acquisition parameters
let me motivate this and explain why we
even need both spatial and temporal
information
take a look at the picture of newton
sitting under the apple tree
which of the apples was the most
important for his discovery of the
principles of gravity
the apple on the ground the apple
hanging on the tree or the apple falling
of course it was a falling apple which
just shows how important dynamics are
take a look at the next picture this
shows fluorescently labeled peptides
binding to a bilayer
but only if i switch on the movie and
you see the peptides moving do you
clearly see the bilayer and its holes
it's a dynamics of the peptides that
show you the structure of the bilayer
we need to record the structure of as
well as the dynamics in a sample to
obtain maximum information about the
system
but this is not everything and we could
be also interested in the aggregation
state of the peptides or whether the
peptide
is just bound to or inserted into the
bilayer
therefore we should aim to apply
multiple spectroscopic techniques
to the same data set to optimize
information extraction
and answer all these questions
simultaneously
let's first talk about some limitations
of fluorescence imaging that make this
task difficult
first we need light sources nowadays
typically lasers for the excitation of
the sample
concerns here are stability the power we
have at our disposal a particular
wavelength range
and whether the source can be pulsed or
modulated with modern lasers this is not
much of a concern anymore
the second factor are the optical
systems for the collection of the
fluorescent signal
the main problem here is detection
efficiency
large fractions of photons are often not
collected in current setups
even with the most modern of instruments
the next factor are the floor force that
provide our signal
we possess a wide-ranging set of
fluorophores from organic dyes to
fluorescent proteins to semiconductor
nanocrystals
here the concerns are flow for
brightness and photostability
but also the strategy to deliver and
label proteins of interest
as labeling is of paramount importance
genetically encoded fluorophores are
often still the fluorophore of choice
despite
their non-optimal fluorescent properties
therefore
we have to often adapt our techniques to
best exploit the information provided by
fluorescent proteins
finally we come to detectors here we
have point detectors
for example avalanche photodiodes apd's
or for the multiplier tubes pmts
or array detectors that can consist of
apds and pmt's
or of course scientific cmos and emccd
cameras
important issues here are the quantum
efficiency that is the amount of photons
detected the time resolution and readout
speed
and the overall signal to noise ratio
so overall especially the probes and
detectors determine our signal-to-noise
ratio
as we have only limited numbers of
photons per molecule and limited
detection of these photons
in addition of course the number of
fortunes detected depends on the time
delta
t and the area of a squared over which
we record the fluorescent signal
and this brings us to the following
problem
a particle creates an image on our
detector of the size of the pointsped
function of the optical system
to capture dynamics we need to acquire
at least one photon in two consecutive
frames
therefore our acquisition has to be fast
enough to capture the particle at least
twice
this requires on one side sufficiently
large pixels and on the other side
sufficiently fast acquisition
to capture the position of a particle we
need small pixels to resolve the psf
and be able to localize it we need to
capture the signal
of the particle on at least two but
ideally more pixels
for any localization the uncertainty in
our localization
is described by the following equations
where
r is a radius of the point spread
function if the particle moves that will
actually increase
a is a pixel size n is the number of
detected photons
and b is a background signal so for good
localization we need small pixels and
slow acquisition to maximize the number
of photons n
so at first glance spatial and temporal
resolution seem to be mutually exclusive
and the number of photons depends on
both acquisition time and pixel size
it seems that we can't optimize both to
record molecular dynamics we use
large pixels that allow us to acquire
the signal fast
and still obtain sufficient signal
levels this results in low spatial but
high temperature resolution
to reach super resolution we need small
pixels resulting in much lower
acquisition
to reach the same signal level this
results in high spatial but low
temperature resolution
so these two approaches are not
compatible and approaching the problem
this why we cannot reach simultaneously
high spatial
and temporal resolution note that in
addition the problem is confounded
by the fact that the number of pixels
recorded determines the time one needs
to read out a frame
and thus this also limits time
resolution
the solution is simple we just record
small pixels at high frame rates
afterwards we've been either in space or
in time to optimize the data for super
resolution microscopy
or the different spectroscopy techniques
we would like to apply
however this mode of measurement became
only possible with advances in camera
technology
and data evaluation strategies modern
cameras can now read out with high
detection efficiency and signal-to-noise
ratio
and they can read out even small pixels
at high frame rates
these are now sufficient to observe the
movement of single molecules
and the advantage of gpus allows us to
evaluate the data
of thousands of frames collected per
second in real time
so let me introduce very quickly the
optical setup that we used in this
particular study
it consists of a commercial total
internal reflection fluorescence
microscope
a wavelength splitter that allows to
record two different wavelength images
on a single camera
and a fast and sensitive emccd or sentix
cmos camera
in our particular case the turf setup is
advantageous as it eliminates only a
very thin slice of the sample above the
coverslip it does avoid background from
the bulk of the sample
and has high signal to background and
high signal to noise ratio
in the last years we have combined
different spectroscopic techniques
measuring dynamics
this includes a combination of imaging
fluorescence correlation spectroscopy
spatial and dual color fluorescence
cross collation spectroscopy
single particle tracking and
fluorescence recovery after
photobleaching
here we will combine imaging
fluorescence correlation spectroscopy
with number and brightness analysis
and superior solution radial fluctuation
microscopy
typically these measurements are
performed in separate experiments or
even use different instrumentation
here i'll show that we actually can
obtain the same information from a
single data set
in the following i'll first explain the
three techniques
and provide some ideas how to perform
the data evaluation
in imaging fluorescence correlation
spectroscopy or imaging fcs
we image the movement of fluorescent
particles on a camera
the crossing of particle through a pixel
will lead to fluorescence intensity
fluctuations in their pixel
the fluctuations contain information of
how the particles move
and how many particles they are so about
the particle's diffusion coefficient and
concentration
evaluation of the odd correlation
function of every single pixel provides
this information
via the width and the amplitude of the
correlation function
longer fluctuations mean slower
particles and produce wider correlation
functions
but as fluctuations are more difficult
to see at higher concentrations
the amplitude of the autocorrelation
function is inversely proportional to
the concentration
meaning that higher concentrations
result in lower amplitudes and lower
concentrations in higher amplitudes
we can depict the diffusion coefficient
and the average number of particles seen
by a pixel in maps
as an example i show here the
fluorescently labeled lipid rotamine pe
in a phase separated by layer
the diffusion coefficient map shows
areas of fast and slow diffusion
while the concentration map shows areas
of high and low concentration
the concentration map coincides with the
turf intensity image
but the diffusion coefficient map is
just the inverse
this is the case as rotary pe will be
trapped in areas where it moves slowly
and has a higher concentration in these
regions
this analysis can be performed on an
image stack by a plug-in for a fiji or
imaging
image j called imaging fcs and which is
freely available on our website
in the next slide i'll show a short
video how to install the imaging fcs
plugin and how to use it
to install imaging fccs on your computer
please start
fiji go to help
and update after a short time
the imagej updater window will appear
then please go to
manage update sites and look for image
signs
click image signs and imaging fcs
close and apply changes
downloading of the files will take about
a minute or so
click ok quit image j
and start again now let's take a look
how to operate the plugin
you will find the imaging fcs program
under the plugin menu
imaging fcs 1.52 being the current
version
when you start the program it will
automatically detect whether there is a
compatible gpu on your computer
if not it will run in cpu mode in my
case on my laptop i don't have a gpu
and run on cpu mode
click on the load button and look for
files you want to analyze
i have prepared here already a file it's
a face separated by layer
open and the program will automatically
tell you how many
images you have in your stack in this
case we have exactly 20 000 frames
now proceed to put in your experimental
parameters into the panel
this consists mainly of the frame time
which is in our case one millisecond
the pixel size of your camera which is
24 micron in our case
magnification and na of your objective
and the emission wavelengths of your
sample
the phase separated by layer has been
labeled with rhodium in pe
and thus our emission wavelength is
around 580 nanometers
to calculate autocorrelation functions
you can click now anywhere within the
image
in the dark part you get very good art
correlation functions as you see
this is a liquid part of the bilayer the
bright part
is a gel phase and here the correlation
functions look very different
if you want to calculate multiple
autocorrelation functions at the same
time
choose a region of interest and click
roi
you'll get now all correlation functions
at the same time
to fit the data click on the fit button
to obtain the fit window the fit window
allows you to use
different models by selecting parameter
values and selecting whether they are
free
or to be fixed during the fit in this
case we will fit only the number of
particles that is the amplitude of the
correlation function
and the diffusion coefficient of one
component
again click anywhere in the window
you see now the correlation function in
blue and in red the fit
we have now three new windows we get the
residuals of your fit we get a window
which will contain the map
of the parameters in your image and a
histogram window
with a distribution of parameters
if you want to obtain the correlation
functions and their fits for the whole
image
please click all now the program will
calculate all correlation functions and
fits
it will open as well a log window where
it'll tell you if there were any
problems in fitting any of the functions
here you see now all correlation
functions at the same time you see that
we have two different kind of
correlation functions
good correlation functions from the
fluid phase and the less well-defined
correlation functions from
the gel phase you have here now a
parameter window
and you see here now as well the
distribution the first
map is the number of particles
you see that wherever we have a large
number of particles
we have bright regions where we have a
low number of particles
we have dim regions in the turf image as
expected
if we switch over to the map for the
diffusion coefficient
we see exactly the offset wherever we
have
a large number of particles we have low
diffusion coefficient
that's a gel phase and wherever we had
low number of particles we have
very fast diffusion correlation between
the number of particles in the diffusion
coefficient can be explained by the fact
that in the regions where the molecules
move slowly they will spend more time
thus you accumulate a large number of
particles in the gel phase
while in the fluid phase the rhodamine
pe moves very fast
and does not accumulate
if you want to review particular
autocorrelation functions you can just
select the region
in the map and then you get only the
correlation functions
with their fits corresponding to that
particular region
if you go to the dark area you get the
correlation functions for the gel phase
this is now only a very basic overview
of the imaging fcs program
if you want to know more about all the
parameters
in the panel as well for the fits please
go to documentation you can find on our
website
thank you very much
in number and brightness or n b analysis
we again look at the fluorescence signal
in a single pixel
if you define the number of particles in
the pixel as n
and the brightness is epsilon then the
average fluorescence signal
is given by the brightness times the
average number of particles
the variance of the signal will be given
by the average of the brightness times
the fluctuation in the number of
particles squared
since epsilon is a constant this is
equal to epsilon squared
times the average of the squared
fluctuation signal
the number of particles seen by a pixel
follows a poisson distribution
therefore the variance of n is equal to
the average number of particles n
with this we can define now the average
fluorescence signal
as epsilon times n and the variance of
the fluorescence signal
as epsilon squared times n
so we arrive at definitions for the
average number of particles and
brightness for our number and brightness
analysis
since cameras are not photo encounters
these values have to be corrected for
camera offset and noise
and finally one has to take care to
eliminate
shot noise contributions to the variance
which can be done by calculating the
covariance of neighboring intensity
values
as has been shown by unru and gratton
this provides good estimates for n
b analysis as long as the time between
measurement points is much smaller than
the time a particle remains in the pixel
the problem however is that we need a
good calibration sample to determine the
brightness of monomers and dimers
for this purpose we have created monomer
and dimer constructs of fluorescent
proteins
that are bound to the plasma membrane
over a so-called plasma membrane
targeting sequence as shown here
this task is complicated by the fact
that not all fluorescent proteins are
fluorescent
therefore even the dimer constructs
comprise molecules with none
single or both fluorescent proteins
being fluorescent
it can be shown however that the ratio
of the brightness of the dimer construct
compared to the monomer construct -1
just represents probability of a
fluorescent protein to be fluorescent
this assumes that the fluorescence of
the two proteins is independent
we have performed these measurements for
the fluorescent protein m apple
we used various exposure and measurement
times to determine what optical
acquisition parameters provide stable n
b values
on the left and middle graphs you see
the monomer and dimer brightness for pmt
and apple
for measurement times between 20 to 100
seconds
and for three different exposure times
per frame of 2
10 and 20 milliseconds
on the right side we depict the dimer
monomer brightness ratio
it is evident that although the values
do not vary strongly they stabilize at a
value of about 1.5
for measurements longer than 60 seconds
and exposure times longer than 10
milliseconds
according to these measurements the
exact probability of a maple to be
fluorescent is 53
which is quite good for red fluorescent
protein
measurements in the rest of the webinar
were all evaluated with 20 millisecond
exposure
in 100 seconds measured on time
in the next slide i show a very short
video of how to perform n b
analysis in the imaging fcs plugin
with the input matching fcs plugin you
can also perform number and brightness
analysis
this we typically do at longer frame
times 20 milliseconds
in this example
for the number and brightness analysis
we first need a background file that has
the same dimensions in the same number
of frames as our actual file
press on the background button and
select the background file
now press on load to select the file you
want to analyze
we have here a cho cell expressing pmtm
apple which is a membrane-bound
fluorescent protein
let's take a look at the image stack
there are two things to realize
first intensities outside the cell are
typically below 2000 counts
intensities on the cell are way above
3000 counts
so to analyze only pixels on the cell we
can set
an intensity threshold of 2700 counts
secondly you realize that if you look at
the stack
that the sample is bleaching therefore
we will use a bleach correction
based on polynomials of first degree
now you can go to number and brightness
analysis
we will do a g1 analysis as explained in
the webinar
and press and then b the program will
warn you that you have less than 100
data points for the last correlation
channel which is fine
after about a minute or so you'll see
two new windows appearing
the blue one will be the information
about the number of particles
that's very similar to the articulation
analysis we've done before
the yellow one will show you the
brightness values
repeating the analysis for monomeric and
dimeric fluorescent protein constructs
allows you to calibrate the system and
determine how many of the fluorescent
proteins are actually fluorescent
then you can continue and analyze your
sample of interest
let me make a small but important remark
as indicated earlier the collection of
thousands of frames per second results
in large amounts of data that have to be
evaluated
ideally in real time cpus are not
capable of performing these tasks
but with the advent of gpus we can
parallelize and accelerate calculations
for number and brightness analysis as
well as imaging scs
the two plots here show the time taken
to evaluate an image stack
as a function of the number of pixels
per frame
the plot on the left is for imaging fcs
autocorrelation function calculations
and data fitting
the right plot for nb analysis
in both cases gpu analysis is faster
starting with about 100 pixels per frame
and from about a thousand pixels per
frame the gpu is about 20 to 40 times
faster than the cpu
for example the full imaging fcs
evaluation
of a 128 times 128 image stack
including data fitting takes around 36
seconds on a titan xp gpu
but it takes 20 minutes on a
state-of-the-art i7 cpu
let's look now at the biological
question we'd like to address
the epidermal growth factor receptor or
egfr is a prototypical receptor tyrosine
kinase
that has been studied over many years
nevertheless there are many unanswered
questions about its activation mechanism
it is for example still debated whether
egfr exists in dimeric form before
ligand binding or only once ligand is
bound
second although there is evidence that
each of our interacts with the
cytoskeleton
it is not known whether these
interactions significantly influence
receptor mobility and oligomerization
here we aim at answering these questions
does eg var exist as dimers before
liquid binding
and does it interact with a cytoskeleton
to answer these questions we need to
have accurate knowledge where the
cytoskeleton lies under the plasma
membrane
and whether at these positions the
receptor mobility is modulated
or whether it oligomerizes in other
words we need high spatial and temporal
resolution
let's start with nmb and its calibration
on the left you see turf images of pmt
and member monomers and dynamics
in the middle you see maps of the n b
analysis of the constructs in cho cells
as can be seen from the brightness
values the dimer has a much higher value
although it is not double of the monomer
brightness
if you plot the histogram of the
brightness values it also becomes
apparent that the pmt methyl dimer
is brighter than the monomer although
the distribution strongly overlap
if you perform the same measurements on
egfr mapple
in the absence of ligand we get a
brightness that is slightly lower than
that of the dimer
we see the same if we plot the eg var
brightness histogram
in black on the right the histogram
lies somewhere between the red monomer
and the blue dimer curve
further analysis shows that this can be
explained if at least
63 percent of eg of r is in a dimeric
state
in line with earlier findings by us and
other groups actually even higher
oligomers cannot be strictly ruled out
after demonstrating imaging fcs and
optimizing n b analysis
we now come to the optimization of serv
the computational super resolution
method used here
the advantage of surf is twofold first
it is readily available via an imagej
plugin that runs on gpus
second as it is computational we can
optimize our spatial and temporal
binning to optimize the data for self
that said note that any other
computational super resolution or the
convolution algorithm could be
integrated as well
surf has been explained in another very
benign detail so let me just
recapitulate the basic concept
first serve divides existing pixels into
subpixels with equal value
then it determines in radial direction
where the intensities increase or
decrease toward that pixel
therefore it determines whether the
source of the intensity is likely to be
located at the pixel
second it makes a correlation analysis
to determine whether the intensity is
related to noise
noise would show no temporal
correlations while the signal will have
a correlation fingerprint
this way we end up with structures whose
location is now better defined than in
the original image
and that can serve as a basis for the
comparison of dynamics and structural
data
let's take a look at the cytoskeleton
and cho cells
for this purpose the acting structures
were labeled with life egfp
an acting binding protein all images
were taken with turf at two millisecond
time resolution
the pixel size and object space was 120
nanometers
on the left you see the raw turf image
and the selection of intensity cross
sections across actin fibers
in the middle we have serve applied to
these images with surface pixel size set
to one-fifth of the actual pixel size
that is 24 nanometers at the bottom you
see the cross section across
acting fibers at the same position as in
the first case
in the third graph on the right we
repeated the surf analysis
but now after bending the frames in time
to 20 milliseconds
one can see that the fiber diameter is
measured by the intensity cross section
decreases allowing better localization
of the fiber
extending the surf analysis to 200
millisecond time bend frames
brings down the feature size to about 60
nanometers
just as a control we have performed the
same analysis with two times lower
magnification
as expected in this case the feature
size determined from surf is of course
larger but also potentially creates
artifacts which we will talk about later
for the rest of the webinar we use 200
millisecond time binning
and 120 nanometer pixel size in object
space
for surf analysis
now let's talk about the dynamics
measurements by imaging fcs
on the same data set first we have to
make a difference on how and where the
dynamics are measured
in the schematic here you see an acting
fiber as it is seen by turf in green and
as is seen by
surf in cyan we can measure the dynamics
at different binding
either on the fiber at places between
fibers or just
at the border between the regions if we
use two cross two binning
the signal-to-noise ratio might be lower
but it also samples a smaller area
and will provide more detailed diffusion
coefficient data
four cross four binning has a higher
signal-to-noise ratio
but it will measure not only the fiber
but also of fiber regions at the same
time
thus it will be harder to differentiate
between fiber and of fiber regions
to illustrate this i will show in the
next figures only two cases
namely on and off fiber measurements and
at four cross four binning
correlation functions of four cross four
bin pixels that are located directly
above visible actin fibers provide
a diffusion coefficient of about 1.4
micrometer squared per second
regions between fibers which we label
here as of fiber
show a more irregular shape consisting
of two parts
first a fast decaying correlation
function at short times is marked by the
red square indicative of diffusion
then they show slowly varying artifacts
at long times
which could be related to aggregates in
solution or low amplitude central
movement
that is only seen at small correlation
amplitudes and low signal to noise ratio
if we concentrate on the fast decaying
portion of the correlation function
which we show here normalized to
emphasize the similarity of the decay
we obtain a diffusion coefficient of
about 2.9 micrometer squared per second
this indicates that diffusion close to
the fiber is slower than diffusion away
from the fiber
a reason for this could be the binding
and unbinding of life to the actin
fibers can we improve on that
first let's decrease binning and refit
our data with 2 cross 2 binning each
observation area becomes smaller
the areas between fibers have now so low
signal to noise ratio that they cannot
be fit anymore
these pixels are indicated in white in
the diffusion coefficient map
pixels on the fiber are now better
defined and show a much smaller
diffusion coefficient of 0.77 plus minus
0.53 micrometers squared per second
the lower diffusion coefficient results
from the fact that the pixel is smaller
and now sees mainly the fiber and little
area around
to improve on that even more we can use
the serve map
and use it as a mask for our diffusion
coefficient map
so we will now take only those pixels in
the diffusion coefficient map into
account
that have a self-identified fiber below
this changes the diffusion coefficient
only little but reduces the standard
deviation
providing overall better precision of
our parameter recovery
but this is not the end of the story
let's select on the unfiltered diffusion
coefficient map a region
around the fiber as shown in the green
box
now we can select auto correlation
functions for pixels directly on top of
the fiber according to serve
and pixels right next to the fiber
we can see in this plot that the
articulation function on top of the
fiber has a higher amplitude and thus
higher signal-to-noise ratio
if we plot the number of particles that
is the inverse of the amplitude
we find in all locations that the
highest amplitude that is the lowest n
is on the fiber therefore the fcs data
corroborates the
serve data and the serve data can be
used to refine and select the fcs data
we can go one step further and use fcs
data now to remove artifacts from the
serve data
on the left you see the turf image if
you carefully look inside the yellow box
you see some very weak fluorescence
intensity in there
on the right side you see the serve
corrected d-map serve clearly identifies
the points one to five in the yellow box
as valid structures
let's take a look at the correlation
functions at these points and compare
them to correlation functions found on
fibers in other areas of the image stack
this slide is a bit busy but if you
compare the correlation functions of the
top row
that are from the five points identified
earlier with the autocorrelation
functions in the bottom row
that were taken from clear fiber areas
you can see
that with a possible exception of point
1 all other art correlation functions on
the top row
have a lower amplitude and
signal-to-noise ratio than the
correlation function of the bottom row
therefore we can identify at least four
if not all five points are as
artifactual
and not representing real fibers
with this we can now mutually filter the
serve image and the d map to refine our
dynamics measurements
and remove serve artifacts note however
that this of course does not bring fcsb
onto the fraction limit
but it improves fcs data this is a
demonstration of the validity of the
approach and how dynamics and structural
data complement each other but the real
strength of the approach
lies elsewhere namely
in multi-color recordings here we show
image specs in which the cytoskeleton
was again imaged by life act in the
green channel
we applied surf to the green
cytoskeleton channel as before
in the red channel we record the
epidermal growth factor receptor labeled
with an apple
the red channel was analyzed by imaging
fcs as seen the purple graph
and with n b analysis as seen in the
yellow graph
as we have now collected all these
parameters from the exact same data set
we can now compare the parameters at
each pixel
when plotting a scatter plot of the
brightness versus the diffusion
coefficient
we saw to our surprise in negative
correlation this means that brighter and
thus larger egfr oligomers diffuse
slower in the membrane
as membrane proteins do not follow the
stock's einstein relation
and should have a very weak dependence
on size we hypothesize
that the larger particles are
pre-internalization aggregates
and are in a different environment
it should be noted though that if we
plot brightness
against the serve map there is no
correlation meaning bright particles are
not
in general found close to the
cytoskeleton
finally if we plot the diffusion
coefficient against the surf map
we also do not see any correlations this
indicates that egfr diffusion is not
directly hindered by the cytoskeleton
as there is evidence that the
cytoskeleton influences each of our
diffusion we assume that this action
is indirect and it is the influence of
the cytoskeleton on the lipid membrane
organization
that then changes egfr diffusion
i hope that these two studies convince
you that there is more to be had from
your image snacks
dynamics and structure are two sides of
the same coin they are complementary and
can inform each other
improving structure determination and
dynamics parameter estimation
when performed in multi-color
experiments parameter correlations can
be established
that are not available from sequential
measurements this combination of
microscopy
with spectroscopy measurements can truly
provide new biological insights
as has been shown before for confocal
setups but here
now one does not need any specialized
instrumentation but just needs a fast
camera and any existing turf microscope
with this let me summarize the webinar
we acquire data at high speed with small
pixels
we've been in time or space to optimize
the data for various techniques that can
be fcs nb
surf etc the structural and dynamics
information can be used to error proof
each other and obtain better super
resolution and dynamics data
gpu implementation brings data treatment
even for large areas into the minute
range
and we have shown structure dependent
life hack diffusion
finally for egfr we have shown the
diffusion is related to oligomerization
but not directly to the cytoskeleton
in the future we are working on a direct
camera readout with simultaneous data
evaluation
if you want to have more information on
the image shape plugin for imaging fcs
please go to our website
in the end let me thank again all the
group members who were directly involved
with this work
czech edition harry for all the
measurements and evaluations
check edition yho for the implementation
of the gpu algorithm
daniel for work on direct camera readout
sonia for the help with the graphics
and thank you very much for listening
thank you torsten hello i'm dr al mullen
a product specialist for microscopy
cameras at andor technology
and before we move on to the questions
for the main part
of the webinar i'm just going to look at
some of the
detector solutions that were mentioned
that would be available
for super resolution and fcs studies
so as we've seen detectors play a role
as being
one of a number of key enabling
technologies that we
that we need to help study the inner
workings of the cells so that's the cell
structure and dynamics as well
and in terms of imaging cameras we can
grip these together
into emctd and sc mos technologies
emc cd cameras have long been used for
super resolution
from d storm palm instead and so on
as well as being heavily used for fcs
experiments but in more recent times
there have been more sensitive scmos
detectors and we have seen these
appearing and being widely used in
other super resolution
techniques such as sim as well as dna
paint just for
a couple of examples and these detector
technologies and
the super resolution and fcs techniques
are explained
in more detail in the outdoor learning
center
so i'm just going to cover just very
briefly
some of the main imaging detectors
available and how they may or may not
suit the different super resolution and
fcs experiments
the cd detectors have been the detectors
of choice for a long time
for whenever the utmost sensitivity and
detection of weak
the weakest signals are required and
this is due to this unique on-chip
amplification
that amplifies the signal many fold
so this does not eliminate reading noise
however it allows the signal to be
boosted many times
before it is finally read out and
unfortunately you don't get anything for
free and the downside of this
is this can introduce additional noise
whenever we're dealing with higher
signal levels
and the serial nature of this readout
process and ccd
cameras ultimately limits the speed that
they can run at
in terms of current em ccd characters
we have two examples one is a quarter of
a megapixel
with a large 16 micron pixel format
an example we just mentioned for this is
the andor exon
ultra 897 and the largest available
which is a one megapixel 14 micron pixel
format
and the example of that is the android
exxon ultra 888
and emccd has been around for quite some
time but over the years
it has been refined and we would see
the ultimate versions of these in the
ultra
and the slightly lower cost life series
and also just to mention about
surfstream
surfstream is a live cell real-time
implementation of surf which torsten
mentioned earlier
scmos detectors can be referred to as
active pixel sensors
because the charge to voltage conversion
is performed on the pixel itself and
then
it is read out on a line by line basis
rather than a pixel by pixel
way that it is done in ccd so this
allows for a much
faster readout process and in terms of
sensor developments
most of the recent sensor developments
have been with
scmos although like with ccd cameras
cmos has been around for a very long
time indeed
so with the scmos cameras models now use
the back illuminated technology that had
previously
only been in the ccd scientific cameras
and this allows the quantum efficiency
to be busted
from originally 60 through to 72
to 80 and now through to above 90
reaching up to 95 percent
but with sc moss because we have a lot
of pixel
to pixel amplifiers
and different differences potentially
between them we do have to consider
how any slight very slight pixel
variations
may it maybe need to be considered
depending
on the super resolution or the
correlative fluorescence measurements
that we may be making
would have and for scmos cameras
we can look at two examples um both from
g
pixel and these are both 4.2 megapixel
sensors and one of them has a larger 11
micron pixel and the example for that is
the sona
b-11 and the one with the 6.5 micron
pixel which is a sona 4.2 b-6
and and or sona series of cameras
that's just really something that was
developed to try and extract the very
best potential from these new sensors
that are not available
the first thing we need to consider with
detectors is their sensitivity
they need to be sensitive enough to work
with the signal level that we have
and often we can have a weak signal from
whatever number of fluorophores we're
working with
and in real life having to capture this
against a background
we can also have short exposures we can
be looking at blinking fluorophores
trying to capture dynamic events within
the cell or measure very small
fluctuations in signal intensities
and for live cell super resolution
we need to try and keep illumination
intensities as low as we can
in order to achieve as accurate cell
biology as we
as we can and if we're thinking about
trying to
make use of the data we would be
thinking of
getting better data and captured by the
camera to allow us to get better
data idealized for any downstream
analysis that we need today
and as torsten mentioned there's some
other things we need to
consider that relate to this such as
pixel size with smaller pixels providing
better sampling but less photon
collection
efficiency but then we can also use
pixel benning to try and improve signal
to noise
but the downside of that is we will lose
spatial resolution
if we look at the theoretical
signal-to-noise ratio plots
we can see that with the latest
generation of back illuminated scmos
cameras
they're providing a better signal to
noise ratio than em ccd
right down to somewhere below the 10
photons per pixels mark and of course
this is going to vary depending on your
microscope configuration because you may
use additional magnification for example
which might
impact the effect of pixel sizes uh just
for one example
so um actually in reality we're still
finding that
um many experiments still require the
sensitivity of
emccd so this is not just limited
to single molecule studies we're still
finding quite
an interest in em ccd cameras and
ultimately for the really sensitive work
they're still
required but um
whenever we don't need this level of
sensitivity then we can start to
consider
the back illuminated cameras and look at
the advantages that we know that we can
get from sc mos technology
so now then that we're considering the
back limited scmos cameras
we can look at both the speed and field
a few of the options we have available
so in these two options we can see that
they're both 4.2 megapixel
cameras but of course we're going to get
a much larger field of view
with the one with the 11 micron pixel
size
so this will also potentially allow us
to have
a better signal-to-noise ratio because
we have a much larger photon collection
area available to us
however the other model with the smaller
pixel should be able to allow us to have
better spatial resolution
and in terms of speed we can see um
in these examples here that the um sona
4.2 b-6
is a faster camera um although the
other sona model is still sufficiently
fast for many applications
and whenever we crop the sensor we can
boost speeds much higher we can also see
here with the em ccd cameras they are
still capable of
um quite high speeds um
up to 100 hertz or frames per second
at smaller regions of interest
so for these cameras and we can see that
the sona with the gs 400 bsi sensor
is providing the largest field of view
and still fast enough for many
applications
and this is the largest area scmos
with a large pixel and that means that
it will suit high magnification
such as 100x and when sensitivity is
more important than resolution or having
the highest
speed with the other sona model with the
gs
2020 bsi it is a faster sensor to begin
with
and with a smaller pixel size it also
has a useful
um correlated multi-sampling mode that
allows it
to have a lower read noise and that
drops the noise floor
even lower which is very important for
whenever we're dealing with very low
level signals as ultimately
they are going to be limited by the read
noise
so this particular camera the sona 4.2 b
dash 6 will provide a balanced
performance of sensitivity
high speed resolution and field of view
and it will also have the better
sampling
which is going to be useful for
different things whether that's
deconvolution or localization
based super resolution because it's
always useful
to have improved sampling of the image
and this also makes it suited to the
more common 40 and 60x
objectives according to meeting nyquist
criteria and in terms of the
sona model itself or the sony camera
platform series um
this has been developed from experience
of both
the exo and em ccd cameras and the
previous generations of sc most cameras
in order to extract the best performance
from demanding applications such as
single
molecule super resolution and
fluorescence correlation spectroscopy
so some of these include being able to
access a full sensor
um the sonar 4.2 b-11 has a 62 percent
higher field of view than um
other cameras using that same sensor and
uses an exclusive
anti-glow technology to avoid sensor
glue
and access up to 32 millimeters field of
view
these cameras will also use the
permanent vacuum technology which is
normally only seen
in the exon emc cd cameras and
that allows us to have superior
reliability and cooling performance
and allows us to reach the lowest noise
floor
and because these sensors actually have
quite a large
or quite a high dark current this is
quite important to apply
moderate levels of cooling and
this also helps then where we need to
have slightly
extended exposures and allows us to have
a wider window of operation with these
with these sensors another effect
of the cooling the sensor that we can do
with this camera
is that we also make benefits
in terms of sensor uniformity and
requiring
less pixel corrections and this can be
quite
um important for making
localization or correlative measurements
where we are relying on a uniformity
from one pixel to another
higher quantitative accuracy is another
thing we um took great care on
and this um the sc mos cameras
and such as the sona and also the xylem
models
have a very high linearity of over 99.7
and this allows for more accurate and
precise measurements
of fluctuations and fluorescence and
this is going to be important whenever
we're relying on these to make
quantitative measurements
and another thing that we looked at
as well was to do with minimizing
vibration
within the camera and that is done in a
number of ways
and we also have water cooling as an
option so that again is another
way to eliminate issues with the
vibration
impacting sensitive measurements and
having any impact on trying to
localize a so sometimes only any mctd
camera
will do it's just not possible
for even the latest sc mos cameras to
operate down to
signal photon per pixel levels
and um the exxon ultra 888
will provide the largest possible area
and speeds from emccd
so whenever we don't need that ultimate
sensitivity the
back illuminated scmos cameras like the
sona series
are going to prove to be a much better
solution for super resolution or fcs
so we can make use of the smaller pixels
and
take benefits of the improved sampling
improve spatial information
and potentially get some better
localization accuracy as a result of
that
we can also get higher frame rates
higher speeds and better dynamic range
as well
and the sony models have been optimized
really to deliver and extract the best
from those latest sensors and get the
best accuracy and precision
possible from quantitative measurements
such as
as you as used within super resolution
and fcs
experiments so there's a wide range of
super resolution
techniques out there so experimental
requirements as well are also going to
vary quite a lot
so it's always recommended to contact
one of your local and or representatives
to discuss
whatever may be your specific
requirements
okay thank you so now we can move back
to
questions for the main part of this
webinar
thank you gentlemen for your informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is let's start with this one
what is the best pixel size for fcs and
super res
yeah that's an interesting question so
when we did fcs alone we typically
work with about 240 to 400 nanometers in
in sample space
but that of course doesn't allow you to
do super resolution for a super
resolution you'd like to be on the 100
nanometers or below
so for surf and fcs together we
compromised we stayed at 100 nanometers
and then we can actually bend uh two
times two or four times four pixels
to get a good scs data
thank you torsten now my next question
is two parts
what are the advantages of brightness
analysis by
nmb then fcs on the imaging fcs
instrument
fcs can also determine the brightness
using average fluorescent intensity and
number particle
and how do you correct differences of
sensors in the camera
probably differences of sensor
sensitivity in the camera are directly
affected
to the resulted brightness
yeah that's a very good question so in
principle fcs can determine
uh brightness as well because ultimately
it's just the amplitude of the
fcs curve and the intensity you use in
confocal that works very well on cameras
however
the amplitude is not a good measure for
the the br
for the number of particles so if you
want to have a good
idea about the number of particles you
have to calibrate your camera with a
standard solution
of known concentration for us it's
easier to calibrate
the brightness of a fluorophore than to
try to calibrate the number of particles
in a standard solution especially if you
work on membranes
because we don't have very good membrane
samples where we
know the concentration very well what
one could do
one could do uh compare confocal
microscopy with imaging fcs but then
this makes it uh more complicated the
the
calibration of the force is much easier
as nmb
that's one of the reasons um how do you
correct differences of sensors in the
camera
now uh we calibrate because we have the
construct already we calibrate actually
every sensor
uh with these constructs so and you have
to
uh use a background file for each camera
because each camera is going to have a
slightly different
noise pattern so you need that to
correct your data
but overall what what you saw in the the
number of brightness analysis
the values are actually very constant
once you calibrate it
thank you tristan now we have so many
questions that we're not going to be
able to answer i'm going to squeeze a
few more in
but those questions we can't get to
today during our live q a
they will be answered via the email
address you provided at your time of
registration
so let's try to squeeze a few more in
does this work with light sheet
microscopy
uh yes actually it does so we have done
this in the past as well we have
published on that
the difference between turf and light
sheet microscopy the light sheet is of
course much thicker than the the third
field term is only about
100 nanometers thick so that's actually
ideal for membrane proteins
or for membrane measurements since we do
a lot of membrane measurements we work a
lot of this turf
but we use light sheets for example in
zebrafish we have measured
morphogens morphogen dynamics morphogen
dynamics in
interstitial spaces or in the membrane
in zebrafish with light sheets here
and do we need any special anything
special for
our experiments
well you need a turf microscope or light
sheet microscope
otherwise you need the camera and you
need a software that allows you to do
the
the the correlations or the number and
brightness analysis depending on what
you want
um otherwise uh the technique works with
the
organic flow force it works very well
with a fluorescent proteins as you've
seen here
we almost use exclusively fluorescent
proteins in in cells because it's much
easier to label for us again
so that's all you need and speaking of
labels do we need special labels
well yeah so as i just tried to indicate
um so
uh of course organic dyes are uh give
you a better signal to noise ratio so we
have beautiful knife
curves on artificial biolayers but the
moment you go into a living
system but a cell or or a small organism
uh it is much easier to use fluorescent
proteins as labels
and we have used the right range of
different solution proteins from m
cherry to egfp
so uh they seem to work all all quite
well and they get
same results as we typically get this uh
fcs con focus yes
thank you and we'll wrap with this final
question and we'll go with this one
because it's come in a few times what
about dual color
fccs
yes that can be done as well we have at
the moment showing it only with turf
so we have measured for example where
the egfr dimerization which we have
shown here with nmd we have shown that
before
as well with imaging fccs
we are working at the moment to do this
as well with a light sheet microscopy
thank you tristan now before we go i do
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
again there are quite a few questions we
are unable to answer they will be
answered via the email address that you
provided
i would like to once again thank torson
woolland and dr alan mullen for their
time today
we'd also like to thank labrutz and our
sponsor andor for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it is available for replay
in that email there will also be a
downloadable link a link where you can
download your
certificate of participation we
encourage you also to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
we thank you for joining us stay safe
and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day thank you very much
thanks everyone